hello et Canada et Canada less than two
months ago Cheryl was with Michael Buble
in Toronto gushing over his son Noah but
the three-year-old is now in the u.s.
where he's undergoing treatment for
cancer brazilian publication la nación
is the first to report the news after
Noah was hospitalized with a suspected
case of the mumps
today Michael and his wife Louise Anna
Lopilato released this statement we've
always been very vocal about the
importance of family and the love we
have for our children
Louise Anna and I have put our careers
on hold in order to devote all our time
and attention to helping Noah get well
this comes right after the release of
Michael's ninth studio album nobody but
me I had never worked so hard on making
the record of my dreams
God the record was a comeback of sorts
after Michael took time away from the
spotlight to undergo vocal surgery he
had plans to go on tour film and NBC
Christmas special and host the 2017 Juno
Awards and through the years he's never
held back his feelings towards his
oldest son I love that kid so much and
whenever I'm there I'm there he's a
beauty he's a little beauty I really am
in love with that little dork big-time
today some of Michael's famous friends
shared their thoughts online including
Josh Groban who tweeted my family and I
send all our love and prayers to Michael
bublé's three-year-old son Noah as he
fights cancer stay strong little guy